[Music]
you guys know who I am my name is Kelsey
Hightower I work at Google I specialize
in kubernetes global container engine
and in this talk we're going to talk
about some of the moving pieces when
most people think about the container or
the container development cloud native
workflow so I'm not going to give you a
very prescriptive into n deployment
mythology but I'm going to talk about
the workflows especially the ones that I
use and I've seen some people use in
awhile and I'm also going to incorporate
some of the new things you've heard
about so Google container builder how
many people have heard of the Google
container builder how many people are
good at using it me either so this is
we're in for some excitement
I just finished these demos like seven
minutes ago so I hope they work well I'm
going to need help so anything that I do
any demo that works just claps loudly
are you guys in for that all right so
the agenda today I'm going to talk about
cloud native applications and what they
mean and what I think about them right
so I know a lot of people are trying to
take their existing applications some
people call them legacy applications and
move them into the cloud is that a cloud
native application it's just your app
running in the cloud so difference okay
so I'm going to try to talk about the
things and properties that make an app
cloud native I don't think there's a
huge gap but there's more queue got to
do and I'm going to talk about building
container images so Google container
builder attempts to allow you to build
images without them running on your
laptop now my workflow I typically don't
involve containers at all I do all the
development on my local laptop I just
use local tools around Postgres on my
laptop or my sequel on my laptop and I
only use containers for the last mile
for packaging and deployment so I don't
really get into those workflows so now I
actually have a different to walking use
and then the last one is that I hear a
lot is how do I manage multiple
environments how many people are running
kubernetes in production just raise your
hand like your line
it looks really cool for the camera how
many people are sharing that cluster for
development whoo yeah you guys are going
to be on the news I'm looking for that
postmortem
you know what's coming we're going to
talk about some patterns that I've seen
for doing kubernetes responsibly okay
now this isn't the only way of doing
things there's something for you to
think about so the first thing I want to
talk about is a cloud native application
how many people have built one of these
these are the same people running
production and dev in the same cluster
I'm worried about the so Cloud Data
think so here's what I think about cloud
native pretty straightforward to me they
build on top of the total 12 pack two
things so if you heard the 12 fact in
manifesto I boil that down into writing
applications that decouple themselves
from the environment okay so that made
it really easy for people to adopt past
platforms like App Engine move around
and adopt new platforms that come out so
a lot of people they have already bitten
off the 12 factor pattern found it
really easy to adopt something like
doctor or kubernetes because their
application was already self-contained
and did a few things that let them adopt
a new platform and the other one is
scale horizontally so this is one where
I think when people enter the container
world especially something like
kubernetes for the first time they're
trying to build their applications of
saying what they did on the virtual
machine and that's just not how
kubernetes is designed why it's the idea
here is that you would specify your
workload in these units that could scale
horizontally and then honestly you want
the application to be much smarter how
many people are still writing Nagios
scripts
that's my ops people you hate your
developers don't you like I'm not
writing any more scripts like building
to the app so I think cloud native
applications will expose health checks
they'll do things like application
tracing they'll have all these metrics
built in and they need to be operable
and we'll see what that means in a
second here now the other caveat is that
this isn't just for micro services a lot
of people like all we going to adopt
micro services and Cabernets and cloud
native
time that just doesn't work out well if
you have a monolith application some of
these patterns still apply and we're
going to check out one of my example
applications in a moment here so I'm
going to do a demo of this application
so this is going to be a little gift
builder application going to show you a
little gift that we have so Google has
all these little doodles here's one of
my favorite doodles from Google so I'm
going to open this with my browser maybe
you've seen this doodle before maybe not
so this guy is a serious business okay
this is some like this fruit Olympics
and there's like a thousand images here
and we need to remix this a little bit
so I want to make this a little bit
easier so what I did here was export all
these individual images and I'm going to
send it to my own little service here so
first I'm going to do is look at all the
images that are built from this
particular thing here's all the
individual images that it takes to make
that particular thing I'm just going to
take a few of them and send it to my own
service now when I look at the design of
my service I'm doing a couple of things
one I want to make sure that my
application can run anywhere in the
globe even startups or even small
companies now have this notion from the
customer that their app should run
anywhere and scale across multiple
regions now this is super hard
especially if you're trying to run with
data stores yourself so for this demo
I'm using a cloud native database we
call it spanner and span is going to let
me just off lift all of the thinking
about distributed transactions all the
sequel stuff to spanner itself so I'll
be using that in this demo and I'm also
going to avoid POSIX if you're a system
administrator POSIX and kubernetes don't
go together
I see people try it all the time they
take things like NFS and try to run it
through out at River native cluster how
many people have dealt with NFS and
kubernetes clappy do you like it no
clamps
it's hard so in this case I'm going to
use an object store so when I process
these images I'm going to store them on
Google Cloud storage so here we're going
to start our application so this little
command I'm going to build my app go
this in on port 8080 I'm going to define
a dev bucket spanner database many
people have played with spent already Oh
awesome
three people we need to have more than
that so here we're going to run our app
so the first thing I do is build it so
go build so this is all live I'm
hopefully I'm hoping it works please
work let's actually install it so can be
in my path
remember if anything works you guys go
crazy okay all right so we're going to
run this all right so we're listening so
the first thing I'm going to do is just
use curl to post images to that running
on localhost we'll see what the results
look like 8080 so if this works from a
laptop we'll be writing into spanner and
then we'll actually be storing images on
cloud sequel or on cloud storage mmm
buddy I don't know I don't know if you
to improve my odds at all well waiting
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait don't
be clapping into it works we'll see
let's see did we get to be remixes
okay so this is our cloud native
application now so this thing needs the
clouds this way to work and what you
have internet access we can actually
deploy our stuff so let's look at where
all this stuff is stored
okay so let's poke around here and see
what our application is doing to make
sure we can replicate it when we deploy
it to kubernetes so the first thing we
look at here is spanner so what I'm
doing inside a spanner I'm giving it a
set of credentials and all the libraries
to access spanner just assume that you
have your service account and path and
I'll show you how to deploy that in the
tool by kubernetes so here we'll click
around and I've been writing an events
to our dev cluster and we come over here
and we look at our events something's
like magic want to talk about spanner I
know right so here we'll make sure that
we see our events inside okay so we'll
run the query all right so we see our
events are being righted in here and I'm
just dropping in the path to our actual
image that I was just sharing and then
I'm storing all the images inside of
Google Cloud storage so now my app is
free to move around so now that we have
this cloud native application we need to
move on to talk about packaging it now
the other thing that I do is it took a
while to run that right and we talked
about built-in monitoring for your
application so one thing I like to do is
use tracing regardless and annotate and
trace everything I can to know what's
going on in my app so this is a
stackdriver trace I'm just going to
click on one of these might one of my
traces that I had before and what you
can start to see here is just like
import a few lines of code and now I can
actually see the span of time that's
taken for my actual request you can see
here about five hundred and some-odd
milliseconds is uploading those images
to Google Cloud Storage so I can do the
processing and then logging the event to
spanner so all the round trips and
formatting the particular thing that
needs to go into spanner
so deploying an application like this
out-of-the-box it makes it really easy
for me to figure out what's going on
without digging into the source code all
right so this is what I mean by cloud
native and there's other ways you can do
this but I think having these properties
out of the boxes the things that take us
from 12 factor and move a step
or can run in any environment with this
kind of visibility alright so let's move
on to the next step so that's your cloud
native thing so now let's get to this
container builder so we have our app and
the price of admission for these
platforms is it needs to be in the
container image and I you succeed docker
on maximum on docker for Mac on my
laptop just so I can build these images
and push them to a registry but really
what I want is just some service or
something else that can do it really
when I check in my code I wanted to
happen how many people are building
containers on their laptop keep your
hand up if you're pushing to production
from that same image whoo that person is
dangerous
pushing container images from your
laptop it works I don't recommend it so
we have something like Google Cloud
builder so the goal here is there is
going to be a fully managed service it
has a REST API the idea here is that you
can connect to it from other tools or
the CI systems and then here also
supports things like build triggers tags
or other custom build steps and the idea
here is that it has full integration
into Google container registry now this
is the same service that we use for App
Engine flex cloud functions those
services uses underneath the covers and
you'll also have access to it and you
also can use your own custom scripts and
we'll walk through what that looks like
here so let's jump over to the container
builder so now that we have this binary
up and running we can verify that it
works we want to build it now ok so the
first thing you're going to need is one
of these cloud build like animal cells
so what we see here is basically a list
of containers so you have a list of
steps just like any other build system
and the first thing we want to do is
specify the container we want to use for
this particular step so in this case I'm
just going to use one of the default
images from the cloud builder team so
this has golang in it has the latest
version of gogo 1.8 is in there so all I
have to do is specify the container I
want to use that's going to mount my
source code into a workspace directory
and then run the commands that I specify
so here I'm just going to say go install
which will then produce a binary that
will be available for me in the
workspace directory for the next step so
now we kind of get this pipeline thing
going
the next step is I'm just going to use a
docker container and what I want to do
here is just called docker build now
what this will assume here is that I
have a docker build file in my workspace
so if I look at this docker bill file
you see here that I'm adding the binary
that comes out so inside of my go path
there'll be this gift maker binary I'm
just copying it and that's the only
thing there I'm just using Alpine as a
base image some people will say hey why
are you not using the scratch image
normally when I'm deploying things like
to production sometimes I do need to get
in there troubleshoot and not having
some kind of base image there the have
some utilities or the ability to add
utilities makes it a little bit harder
to troubleshoot especially if you're in
production so I usually use a very small
minimal image like this so given that if
we were to push this we should create
this particular image from our source
code so we'll run that command now now
I'm going to cheat and rely on my
history to know what command that is so
what we want to do here is take that
config take our current context and push
it up to container builder I don't know
want to know your data plan is going to
be but ax is going to be a little
expensive alright so what we're doing
now is turning up all the contents we're
pushing it to container builder and
that's pretty this is actually pretty
good idea because now that we're not
building pulling down all those docker
containers on my laptop because your
data plan would be just totally screwed
if I did that we're doing all this on
the other side on the server side so all
the logs here are available and
stackdriver logging so what you have
here now is all the steps are coming out
here and if everything works what you'll
see is we'll have our resulting image
push to container registry automatically
now the tool is smart enough to use your
service credentials or anything that you
have set up an item so it pushes to the
right place and once it's there it's
available for me to use now if I were to
pop over to the container builder UI
which is part of the container registry
UI we click over here and we also have
all your build histories so here you can
kind of drill in to all of your logs to
see what happen you can drill into each
individual step if you want to and this
is what you can kind of long and see
things that are working
and now that we have this particular
image available we can look at our
container registry and we'll see that
the image should be there so let's find
it here gif maker and we'll see that
it's tagged there so at this point we
should be able to push our application
to our development environment so let's
talk a little bit about the registry
before we do so the container registry
the goal of this and why did we build
this why not just use the docker hub
well number one people want the
container images to be accessible and
make them fast so having Google
container registry means that your
images are stored inside the same cloud
infrastructure it's backed by Google
Cloud storage all your images are
replicated you don't have to worry about
those things and it's private by default
so it has integration - I am so all the
things you're using for the rest of your
resources we piggyback on top of those
things some of the other things the team
is really up-to-date on the image format
we support so dr. v2 image format and as
OCI continues to make progress that's
the open container image format we'll
have support for that too
vulnerability scanning will be built-in
so if you look at some of the command
line tool and you start to see hints of
that in our UI and the goal here is that
we'll start by notifying if there's any
vulnerabilities found in your image
maybe inside of your base image tools
we'll get more advanced and start doing
static analysis to tell you how you're
using a vulnerable library you might
want to update that and do a rebuild and
it's backed by Google cloud stores like
we saw before now when you're using this
you can definitely use a command line to
do most things so you can lift tags for
all your images and here's where you
would see any vulnerability reports that
show up so here's our first image that
we pushed you can list all the images
you have there even though this seems
like a simple thing most container
registries do not have a way for you to
figure out what the tags are you have to
like go to the GUI and drill down so
having this on the command line is super
easy for me to figure out what I want to
play with him what I want to deploy so
all this kind of built in all this is
integrated so so far we've talked about
building the cloud native app this idea
that we want to build it but
we don't want to build things from our
laptop we want something like a build
trigger okay
so now that I have this application what
I really want to do is set up a build
trigger that will automatically build
this app but not on every check-in I
actually experimented with having a
container built on every check-in I mean
if you have run out of disk space before
that's what that feels like okay so what
I found works a little bit better is
build the containers on tags so when I
tag something that's what I want my bill
to actually happen so here I'll go to my
build triggers and I can define one so
here's a build trigger and the UI is
pretty nice you can go through and pick
particular Hosting repositories like
github and here I want to have a tag
trigger a build and when that tag shows
up matching my regular expression I
wanted to run the command in the cloud
build that gamal so we need to make one
modification for this actually work so
we want to instead of hard-coding the
tag number there we want to actually
have it replaced with the actual tag on
the repository so I'll just do like that
whole cooking show thing and then let's
take a look so we'll grab the tag name
and make that our image name and have it
trigger the build that way so we'll push
this up and then we'll tag it so here
we'll just do git status now look at all
that other stuff I don't know if I
should check it in how many people just
do get add and don't even look at it
yeah that guy like hey man who checked
in like their PlayStation games like all
my badges I'll fix it all right so what
we'll do here is a ok I think we just
add it all do you want to see what that
is
that looks safe I think all right let's
just do that let's just do this thing
here so what you should do always is
just blindly do that and then the worst
thing is when people do this updating
you might do how am I going to cover you
that like yeah you updated stuff but
it's not right take it as is dude
alright so now we have this new thing up
ideally it should still bill so next we
want to do is tag it so get tags and
then we'll call it zero dot zero dot one
and then we'll say get push origin tags
what alright so we push this there we
should trigger a build pls beta be
working so the first warning is when you
log in and says this at the top you need
to think about that a little bit so we
come over here oh a bill triggering so
you got some logs
I'm so happy on the inside right now you
guys don't even know it's fast too so
now we have the 1.0 image-based on the
bill trigger so now my workflow could be
build my application test it locally you
might want to answer that as soon as I
have any internet access
push it locally and then once I tagged
the repository I now have this automatic
build triggers I don't have to think
about so all this is kind of built in
automatically in Google container
registry so at this point I'm ready to
start consuming that image inside of my
my container cluster alright so we have
our bill trigger in place so let's move
on to the next step so this is kind of
what we want to have this registry
system we want to be fully automated and
again the design here is that you can
hook up other tools to do this as well
alright so this guy's still working out
he's probably tired so let's talk about
Google container engine if you haven't
used uke the best way to think about it
is we take open source kubernetes we
don't modify it in any way but we do
glue in all the Google Google
services like the lodging from
stackdriver we have Tracy a log in from
stackdriver we do monitoring from
spectra we pull the metrics from the
cluster itself
we take care of all the upgrades and
scaling the nose if you turn on that
option one of the best features of like
is that I am integration so anything
that you use from ku CTL from your
credentials once we have you know the
details are back that will be integrated
to the Alpha announcement we had today
with custom I am roles you'll be able to
map that to your kubernetes roles and be
able to control access and then it's
also easy to manage multiple cluster at
a time now the reason for this is we
want you to focus on using kubernetes
and not managing it now having all this
integration also leads to the next thing
which is managing development
environment now this is where it gets
real confusing for most people the first
thing people do want to get a critical
essays give everyone in the company coo
CTO write that this guy's laughing his
ass off because that leads to a bunch of
problems
number one by default most people are
given out admin credentials so people
are adding things deleting things they
shouldn't delete so we're going to talk
about a better way of sharing a cluster
and development and I do like the idea
self-service you do not want to operate
on a ticketing system to get someone to
deploy something intranet ease we made
it far too easy to use the cluster to do
that so if you're an up the way you
think about this is a provided sandbox
for testing and playing with these
config until they get it right into
production so what we want to do is talk
about how to share a cluster now I think
namespaces is one of the best ways to
share a cluster inside of kubernetes you
can give a namespace to a whole team you
can give a name straight to individual
developers and let them go Wow in that
little sandbox but the key once you
issue that namespace is you want to use
quotas to limit what they can use in
that particular namespace you want to
prevent mistakes right we're not trying
to defend against malicious users we
want to make sure people don't
accidentally consume too much and give
direct access to this so if you haven't
used namespaces we're going to flip over
and show you how people are managing
these things so one thing people are
doing is they have a git repository that
holds allow the infrastructure stuff if
you come from an infrastructure as code
back
and you kind of familiar with this
particular model here this is for
restoring our configs so we want to do
here is we'll have a dev setup so as a
cluster administrator I want to prep
these namespaces and put quotas in place
as a developer I'm assuming my
credentials that are given to me our
scope to that particular namespace and I
can just push to that namespace and deal
with the resources that I have now one
thing is important you have to remember
the namespace and a single cluster is
shared across all the nodes so you're
not going to limit them on what knows
their workloads can land on so you want
to put that quota in place and make sure
that you're sharing resources
effectively so the first thing I want to
do is make sure that I'm using the right
cluster so for those that don't know
coop CTL the kubernetes command line
tool supports multiple clusters you can
just squish between them so here I'm
going to use cout CTL config use context
and then we're going to say dev so now
I'm playing to my dev cluster and here
I'm going to create a namespace this is
really annoying
developer Kay Hightower this guy and
he's just rambunctious think he knows
everything so I'm going to give him his
own namespace and he can go wild in that
particular namespace so as a cluster
administrator I'll say Q CTL apply and
I'll create this new namespace so once
this namespace is in place before I hand
out credentials I'm also going to put a
quote in place here all right so this
quota will prove s allow only one
service probably one of the most
important quote of things people start
creating a bunch of services you have a
bunch of public IPS and you're going to
be spending a lot of money at Google
that's probably a good idea so probably
up that number if you want to we're
going to limit it to three pods and I'm
going to limit the amount of CPU and
other resources that can require so here
we're just going to do an apply here as
well right so now our namespace is set
up now we're able to give our
credentials to the developer so what we
want to do here is limit what we give
them by default I'm just going to switch
context but when you give out your Kubb
configs you can actually put them in a
specific context give them a namespace
so it's just the false to the right
thing right and then maybe live into
credentials on what they can switch to
so here we'll say cube cgl config use
context and here I'll just use the K
Hightower context I don't want them in
the K Hightower context I now have my
own environment in sandbox of plan so if
I say to CTL get pods hopefully there's
nothing running and then also we can
look at our quota so KU CTL describe
folder and we can see the limits that
are put in place ok so at this point
that's all I have to work with so I'm
going to deploy that application that we
had earlier so here I'm just going to
update my deployment so in my dev I
check in my current age configs next to
my application if you're running things
like mini to you on your laptop will
give you a one-note kubernetes cluster
it's a good idea to test out these
configs before you push them up and push
into other higher-level environments so
here what I'm going to do is look at my
trip Rene's config for my deployment
object and you'll notice a few things
here for configuration here you can see
that I'm pointing at the image that we
just built from the tag down here I'm
having my config separated a lot of
people struggle with this idea where do
I put my configuration files I recommend
you do not put them inside of your image
do not build a new image to deploy to an
environment that has your configs in it
coverage makes it too easy for you just
to have your configs parked outside
inside of cover days in this case we're
using config Maps here we're specifying
the database we want to connect to the
bucket we want to use and the project ID
that we need to consume now my
application doesn't necessarily take
environment variables so I'm able to
reference those config maps in my flags
by using this method here where you can
refer to environment variables and
Cooper nase will substitute them before
they're actually deployed now here's the
other bit that you need to think about
when you're managing these environments
even in dev and production you want to
know how your application performs with
these kind of constraints well I thought
the customers is the first thing that
they fall down on most people are used
to having the whole VM a bare-metal
machine at the disposal and they've
never been capped before you take their
application and you move it into an
environment where we start enforcing
speed groups it starts behaving weird
right they just say that
is slow now right of course it is well
throttling how much CPU you can use so
you need to start measuring these things
I would say even at the lower
environments or even on your laptop so
make sure you put in the limits and
request in place and here we're mounting
in our config Maps also my service
account that I need to connect to all of
those resources just like we saw on the
command line the other thing that I do
in my dev environment is I also check in
my configuration options so if you look
here I'm going to connect to the dev
bucket because that's the things that I
have access to I'm going to connect to
the dev database inside of spanner I'm
also going to use my personal project ID
right so as a developer unknown playing
to the right namespace so what we'll do
here is say cout CTL apply dash F and
then we're going to say this whole
kubernetes folder so most people don't
know you can actually just point to a
whole folder and I'll take all the
config and push into kubernetes at the
same time so I have to do them one by
one
now if I push this up we should now have
our configuration files and credentials
all in place and our deployment there so
let's see if it's actually running it is
running as I expect it with lots of
confidence so with this running I can
now connect to it so beforehand I
created a service so crew CTO get SVC
and then we can actually look at our
quota again to see how much we're
actually taking up so that actually cost
me about half of my CPU limit so I'm not
going to be able to deploy much more
here so what happens if you do
accidentally try to scale this out a
little bit so let's try it really quick
so to CTL we're going to scale the
deployment object so I'm going to scale
my deployment inside of kubernetes and
this is going to be called gift maker
replicas equal three and then what we'll
do is we'll also watch for some events
so we actually see what's going on in
kubernetes COO CTO get events - - watch
so here's all the events that are coming
out of our cluster so we're about to
kick-off this command and we're going to
see what happens we want to observe the
behavior so I'm going to ask for three
of these
and as I asked for three of these we get
some errors here
all right so we'll cut this and we'll
see that some of them fail because we
actually hit our quota so we're going to
end up with this only two out of three
pods and the deployment controller
behind the scenes will continue to try
to create the third pod hoping that
quota will show up to allow us to do it
but in the meanwhile we're going to
continue to hit this error and we won't
be able to actually use anymore inside
this particular namespace so if I say
cout CTL get pods we'll only have to
running if I look at my quota we can see
that I'm out of quota and at this point
we can have a conversation with the
administrator or you can be monitoring
the events that are coming out of
Cabernets to say hey we have a namespace
that seems to be needing more resources
and if the cluster isn't fully utilized
you can come back here and add resources
to that particular quote to that
particular cluster so we can bump that
up a little bit it takes a moment for
this name to resolve but we can go ahead
and do it now so we'll say cout CTL
compute resources and we'll bump some of
this up we'll say hey let's go ahead and
give you four here we'll give you eight
here and those are fine and then we'll
say cucit's yellow five so this is me as
a cluster administrator and noticing
that there needs to be something fixed
applied SS compute resources so at this
point there's more quota inside of that
particular namespace we see the limits
have been risen so at this point the
deployment controller will try and try
until it finds room to actually run this
workload so let's see what's happening
Co CTL get pods right so this will take
a moment and then when it realizes that
it will work it will show up so we're
just going to let that continue to
background as we move on to production
so we have one more main use case that I
want to show you when dealing with this
and also how container builder can help
us even for the production situation so
let's look at this really quick this
guy's still doing this thing
so for production environments this is
where I think you should just use a
dedicated cluster one you're going to
want to upgrade kubernetes and try out
new features and the last thing you want
to do is upgrade cover days because you
want to use some new feature for dev to
experiment and take down production all
right you do not want to fill out that
for some mortem there's no reason to the
idea here is that the configs you write
in one environment ideally can move to
the next environment because all you had
to change the config settings between
the different clusters or namespaces and
we saw the resource quotas and limits it
is another thing that I want to show you
that I actually don't have on the slide
I think it's important is like you want
real health checks so when we look at
our production environment and we'll go
over here you want to make sure that
you're actually using things like health
check inside of this so in my case this
is going to be readiness probe and
healthy probe so if I'm doing rolling
updates in my cluster you're not going
to get to zero downtime if you're not
actually checking for status and
readiness inside of your cluster alright
so once we have that and then this is
what I think you need to disable direct
access this is why I think to CTL
probably doesn't need to point to
production ideally you want to give that
to admins and this is where I think you
hooking the CI CD system now those that
are using cover days in production
do you have it wired up to your CI CD
are you doing continuous delivery with
it so not the same number of hands and
most people are confused they're looking
for products that have qu Bernays
integration and I look at them in like
what what does that even mean what would
happen there okay
so what does it take to integrate
kubernetes to your CI CD pipeline so
we'll use cloud builders here to try to
make this work so what I want to do is
remember we're using git for our
infrastructure so ideally I can actually
have my production workloads there as
well so if we look at our production
config
when we look at our deployment here
ideally any changes that I make we're
going to make a change here actually
it's that dev right now and maybe we're
about to launch this service for the
first time so we need to move to
production
and since everything is here ideally I
can just set up a bill trigger to this
repository as well so I can actually do
that so I'm going to go to my bill
triggers and I'm going to set up one for
infrastructure but this time I don't
necessarily want to tag it anything that
gets pushed here I want to have that
automatically roll to production so code
review push it to production and we look
at our cloud builder here
Rhaenys a slightly different one here
I'm actually going to use another
container image I'm just going to bring
in the GS utils so to make this work I'm
going to grab a coop config from Google
Cloud Storage put it in my workspace so
I can access it from my next step now my
next step is going to use KU CTL to do
them apply on the production directory
so ideally for every environment I want
I can have a separate bill trigger just
to handle that piece so if this works
ideally if I push to the master branch
it should automatically update the
containers in that environment so let's
switch to production and see what we
have to CTO config use context
production to CTL get pods all right we
don't have anything running there
hopefully good so let's just put a watch
on this and see what happens
so what we need now is to trigger a
build currently we have dev in our
things and I had a volunteer do a pull
request to my infrastructure so remove
dev image from name who gave me this
pull request raise your hand do you know
what you're doing okay so it's code
review time
okay do not just click merge I have no
idea this is going to actually work okay
we were trying to test this out before
the talk and we ran out of time but you
got the porti question do you think this
is going to work all right because I'm
going to talk about you on Twitter if it
doesn't show me your fault that's not
mine all right so we have this commit
and ideal you just do a code review
right so let's see what's inside of here
so you're stripping this tag and you
want to use this image I am go verify
that this images even real it's
available
so we go over here and we find what is
this thing
gif maker 1.0 that looks that 0:01 looks
alright so this looks good to me
so I'm going to merge this now my hope
is if this works we should trigger a
build now I'm hoping this works alright
so we're going to look at our bill
history so we're going to see if this
triggers a bill at all all right so
let's merge this all right so rebase and
merge okay that did something and then
we have a trigger let's see if it's
actually working so we're running
through our our custom cloud builder
Yambol file for this if it completes
we'll go through the steps are going to
copy in a cube config whenever I'll do Q
CTL apply and if this completes what we
should see our pod show up here and if
it's the right version after our health
checks pass those should be running and
then once they start running we should
be able to hit the public service there
so let's try that qu CTL get SVC oh we
don't have a service so let's just do it
oh I can't take long but there's a trick
so we can do to make this a little bit
faster to CTL get pods
we'll grab this name and then this
little thing you can do qu CTL port
forward okay and then we'll do 88 in my
laptop - 80 inside of that container and
ideally we should be able to push images
into this like we did earlier here we'll
push those up and if everything is
working we get this back
and it works awesome and with that into
the presentation thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]